all right three two one
[Music]
what's up y'all welcome to conspiracy
corner cookie cool I don't even know we
can still use that name I still haven't
done my research I'm gonna use it anyway
your [ __ ] [ __ ] faces yeah today we're
gonna talk about some serious [ __ ] it's
not a conspiracy this is real but they
just found out aren't they all real
that's all [ __ ] though that's true they
call it a conspiracy but it's just not
proven yet we just know the facts before
they do
that's right which is what what is it
well this one today we're talking about
the lost city of Atlantis oh [ __ ] I have
suspicions that they it's not lost
anymore that's an alien base
yeah my only knowledge of Atlantis is
the Disney movie movie sucked ass Disney
movie called Atlantis yeah it was like
toward the end of the renaissance is
this mandela fiction movie yeah and
there's also a TV show called atlantis
it was a spinoff on yeah was it called
Stargate Atlantis or yeah I think so in
my opinion yeah but you know what though
I believe that it was a second city it
was a Sun can see okay so he will be I
don't know people don't that don't know
about Atlantis okay I think it was Plato
or Socrates I forgot one of those Greek
[ __ ] yeah yeah he wrote about
it on his travels to ancient Egypt he
heard about this technologically
advanced city that went through like a
huge what'd he call it like a disaster a
[ __ ] volcano or something and but
before they went through that that the
the the inhabitants were very
intelligent they were almost like space
like with like technology and all this
[ __ ] and it was just like a crazy
utopian technologically advanced place
to be and then they got destroyed yeah
you but see look I believe in that just
because think about Pompeii Pompeii was
pretty developed until like the volcano
Vesuvius
did and completely destroyed the whole
civil I seen the masturbating man and
pompay ride with his Vikki like this
yeah really I think they call him the
masturbating man you know it was his
dick in his hand though oh my god it
looked like I mean it has to be this
really attack it looked like he was in
the middle of beating off any [ __ ]
Kato [ __ ] caught him like he just
wanted one last go before you die and
would people who died instantly like
that like new stuff like that that's
probably happened to a lot of I wonder
if you're a middle of [ __ ]
simultaneously oh my god do you think
that it wasn't that maybe they got
discovered by Plato and they're like oh
[ __ ] one of the commoners found us and
then they just kid what location are
they saying in some phase like in the
ocean at the mid-atlantic rift
some people say sorry so by the time
they got a [ __ ] Greek philosopher got
it it was already hundreds of years like
like you know you know there was some
time that it wasn't during the air they
weren't a little alive during the same
era right so but when he when he wrote
about it he says that it's basically
it's like off of the Atlantic Ocean all
like past the Mediterranean so like it's
somewhere around south of Spain and like
where I think Algeria or whatever is
about utopia that's a nice ass area to
Hamlet I mean it's all the same equator
line like you know Mediterranean like
it's all I have a different through
water and the Bombers of so much man so
a lot of people have been looking in the
Atlantic Ocean for like you know since
the dawn of time and I think when they
looked for America that was one of the
things that they were looking for
looking for Atlantis yeah they're
looking for a long way maybe we'll stop
imagine looking for Atlantis and you run
into Florida instead
order today yeah it's like a bunch of
girls with big butts and you're like oh
I found the [ __ ] senior guy you went
to Miami you'd be like [ __ ] yeah that is
true
oh my god people have evolved so much
too I feel like like people are just
getting better-looking every year right
so then what did people think in the
past cuz they were ugly as well yeah
this is standard of beauty is people are
just healthier and hotter now looking
like the Victorian Daisy we're like more
plump women and that was that was what
they it meant that you were like yo and
fat is what they really really like cuz
it meant that you were eating well
exactly eating well I'm not going
outside dude I love a fat mom being
against like trans people when it's like
you look like a man who [ __ ] you there
goes our fat mom body but they adapt to
it now
the ones when I'm a fat mom come on I
mean you're gonna be a fat mom yeah
probably
you're waiting for the day I'm like why
would your mom fat honestly that's what
she do sometimes you look at the mom
yeah we're weird the trajectory mom is
blond and white like John we look I
would not anything study I still don't
believe you know you said to hear now I
stood on but I didn't believe it either
in the torso yeah Abby's mom yeah she
looks like she could be Stevie she are
to get the people think of those mom
she's got green eyes and Steve has brown
eyes even that I'd be like oh you didn't
get together it looks like my mom and
Nikki's dad are dating I would
absolutely believe hot dude so they also
think piggybacking off of Atlantis they
also think that they found Noah's Ark in
the mountains of Turkey that's where it
should be
story-wise Mountain iRobot they would be
3d they 3-d mapped a ship like structure
on the mountain did they see what looked
until they look inside it of course not
you can't ever crack the actual mystery
yeah just see well they don't allow
Americans and researchers there as I saw
the documentary it was like really
difficult to get up there because of the
political issues like Egypt where you
try to go to the pyramids there's so
many rules about it oh you can't like
stop taking our bricks off the pyramid I
thought this is America so I can be part
of history what's great about the Great
Flood to you is um what's great about it
what's interesting about a that actually
happens in a lot of different cultures
like all having this flood mythology or
the same - Drock yeah a very similar
time period so it's like even if we
don't think it's like this huge like God
made it rain for there like it's
something we did we did go through a
mini ice age like 11,000 years ago or
something like that and supposedly like
the world goes through one every ten to
twenty thousand years yeah cool
do right now is supposed to be the
global ohmy warming effect where
wherever is it's happening the
transitioning is happening right now so
it's gonna start getting colder well why
don't we keep uh why don't we just start
building more high-rises like to avoid
this flood based on three pillars look
at look at the Middle East right now man
they build the tallest buildings right
yeah I'm going to Dubai I know all right
going right up there won't take women
entrance is gonna be flooded though yes
you guys know the higher entrance nobody
have that they're having like gardens
and parts in the middle of these
structures and they're having it you
know bee sting like Waterworld
yeah no matter that other movie wasn't
where there that Matt Damon we were they
all went to the they have that had the
like space yeah at least yeah yeah why
can't we just move to mountains is that
the mountains will turn into Hawaii
rich people keep on buying a beach front
property and they keep on saying the
oceans are about to rise and they keep
on buying written brick private property
do you think it's that it's the partial
danger they get some excited there's
maybe my blush too boring I want to see
what like why are they doing that house
to be where do you think the Bahamas are
those are going under first then your
liens Florida beautiful beautiful oceans
that you're talking about they're about
to be in your house
I want to talk an artificial city of
Atlantis what are we talking about
floatable houses like they all are built
with flotation devices in the foundation
so that when the water rises and the
house rises they're saying that what do
you call it the [ __ ] Ice Age thing
with all the water level rising and all
that it destroyed the city of Atlantis
and there was like a volcano or
something
so okay no an asteroid dam yeah we know
when the mr. Greek philosopher he mapped
out like measurements of what that city
was it had like three circles and all
that measured it or there was magic
there were measurements on that city
right based off of Egyptian script or
something like that it was based off I
heard whose based off his dick length so
you take you take your base of your palm
and then you go up to your finger right
here and then he was walking around the
city like like that my god was dick like
measuring it out one one one dick length
at a time so what's cool is uh in
western Africa right there's this
country called Mauritania it's right
next to Mali right and Molly was a big
African Empire and leading buck to you
as I created okay always hear about like
good back in Timbuktu as well as the
actual place and they're all true
the predecessor to that to that Empire
was Atlantis and they found a structure
that had those exact it was like a
bull's eye target and the city was in
the middle with three molt's and her
saying that that area was Atlantis yeah
but it got destroyed destroyed or just
how many [ __ ] like tombs were there
in ancient Egypt
apparently find one every [ __ ]
anymore well that doesn't really took
over Larry I think he put in a little
bit man let's put too many what if you
were talking about conspiracy theories
all day to day all of these things I'm
sure have a Discovery TV special
Discovery TV is really the one at the
top and they're just being like we gotta
create another [ __ ] they just so happy
to drop this bucket documentary crew
luck Oh found another to handling ghost
hunters yeah and they use the same props
every time it's always the same
sarcophagus same amount of dust you
think there's a formula to it is like I
won one tomb for every like ten pounds
it does an algorithm and discovery is
the creation of the simulation oh yeah
they're making new worlds you know like
Minecraft if discovery is at the top of
it online I might be okay with living in
the simulation that's a hard desert some
massive it's like the size of America we
haven't gone to the bottom of the ocean
yet like how we haven't even begin to
the Mariana Trench yeah yeah every time
it's looted they find half a mummy or a
full mummy do you think they using the
same mummy over there like nobody could
know yeah you know a mummy unwrapping
party was a very popular thing to do in
Europe back in it so when they had a [ __ ]
mania right yeah they were she was
[ __ ] crazy by the mummies and rich
families would have like the sarcophagus
yes to create a body like yeah I mean
like for them it's just like it was
nothing - yeah that's true let's have
unwrapping party guys it's like mystery
that's old-school YouTube unboxing like
find out in the next step what do you
think a stand-up was like back then
because you know how they always say
stand-ups always like times are crazy
right now times were crazy yeah like
times are crazier and that times are
crazy people rape in a lot of rape and
going the jesters are were the ones that
reflected they were like the stand-up
comedians yeah true reflected what was
going on yeah
[Music]